foreign
is kicking us off in Des Moines Susan
welcome to the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hi thanks for taking my call happy to
take it what's going on hey so I'm
watching about the um the current
hurricane that's heading towards Florida
and yeah I live in Iowa so we get lots
of tornadoes here and I was thinking if
um something wiped out the power in this
area a big natural disaster and I didn't
have access to my emergency fund how
much cash should I have on hand just in
case hmm
interesting question how much do you
have in your emergency fund right now
I have over a thousand dollars right now
okay what baby step are you in have you
been following the plan I've been
following the plan yeah so
um uh I want to say like two and a half
to three so you still have some debt
I do still have some debt that I'm down
to less than 15 of My overall available
okay how much debt do you have left
um I have about fifteen thousand okay
and then a thousand in the bank
yeah cool all right well I mean I'm not
counting my mortgage in that 15 pounds
sure that's your Consumer Debt
yeah okay well you called the right show
at the right time because I have the
prepper himself Dr John deloney this man
has enough deep freezers to last a
century yeah I'm more into
um
uh
food and things like that more than I'm
cash so
um hey this is actually a like I grew up
in Houston so very similar tornadoes and
hurricanes all the time just kind of a
part of life
um so I'm gonna tell you what I think
I'm gonna tell you what my reality is is
that cool
yeah
um what I think is a small amount of
cash that it which is that number is
going to be relative to people what I
consider a small amount of cash and what
Dave Ramsey considers a small amount of
cash very different numbers right
um but
what would I what would I need to give
me a couple of days if I needed to go
stay in a hotel if I need to leave town
um and drive a couple hours away and put
gas in the car like very basic if I need
to go get some food and groceries and I
didn't have access to a b or c
um it's balancing this what could happen
with like what's probably gonna happen
right and as a the son of a homicide
detective I was raised to believe it
could all come down at any moment
because that was that was my dad's world
and so that's my natural bent and I've
had to train myself over the years too
it could but it probably will right it
probably won't so I have no problem if
you have a thousand dollars in emergency
fund that you keep 250 500 bucks at home
um in cash just as a I can go get a
hotel and I can drive somewhere and be
somewhere for a couple hours or I could
drive 24 hours and get out of here and
go stay with a friend right that's what
we're looking for
um
the idea that if the whole banking
system goes down the the cash is worth
the paper it's printed on right so right
um we tend to overdraw we tend to
pretend that the world after some kind
of crazy Calamity that the world would
exist as it does and I have a friend
who's a banker and he's like dude if the
whole world goes down you're going to be
shooting your neighbor for water and
barbecuing dogs like like the world as
you know it is over right so it's not
like my cash is going to help here's the
other side
um I am I don't say I'm a prepper I'm
just someone who's prepared how about
that sure that's literally a different
verb um yeah I'm but
um I live in the woods and I have a
Year's worth of meat on hand right now
that's right so I some would call me a
Georgia call me a prepper I live in a
neighborhood in a society it's a little
different exactly but there is wisdom in
what Johnson but I don't have any cash
at my house right now I don't have five
thousand dollars hidden at home I have
I've done that before I don't have that
right now
um I'm not super concerned about it
okay there's a spectrum from like a
tornado may be coming versus like it's
the apocalypse which I've seen Left
Behind very scary anytime I see a pile
of clothes I'm nervous I'm like did I
get is this it is it happening it's gone
but Susan I think it's wise if you have
a thousand bucks right now in the bank
if you want to take out 500 of that in
cash and put it in a fireproof safe I
think there's some wisdom that's gonna
help you sleep cool yeah but I also
wouldn't go yeah once you're out of debt
and you're fully funded what you guys
thought yeah once you get like 10 000 in
the bank maybe up it to a thousand in
that safe to having cash just in case
even Beyond a natural disaster sometimes
you just need to have cash on hand uh
your bank accounts got locked up for
some reason yeah there's wisdom in that
during the tornado that came through
Nashville here um I don't know when the
last time you were in like a an event
where power went out for a couple of
days or something like that but I was
stunned at how fast technology has
shifted people were able to buy things I
was able to buy something with my debit
card on somebody's cell phone because
they had one of those little plug-in
things it just they it went very very
quickly is what I'm saying so that I
like I grew up one time when Hurricane
Alicia came through we had nothing for
like 10 days like nothing we cooked on a
camp stove it was the whole deal
um
in some parts of the world that still
happens in some parts of our country
that still happens it's very very rare
do you feel better Susan
I do I just you know like I've got my
dry food and my water and blankets and
whatever else and I was just thinking
wow I don't have any money am I gonna
need to put some of that aside so I
wanted to know what your thoughts were
on it in my life the more cash I have at
my house the more money I spend on stuff
that I really don't need that's that's
that's it's a it's a self-control
mechanism that's why I like keeping it
in the fireproof safe not just gonna sit
in the wallet John that's how it
disappears but this is a real John
regardless of what the reason is natural
disaster or something else there's a lot
of fear like I get messages probably at
least once a week if someone going but I
was watching the news and what if and
what if the digital money and currency
goes digital and I I saw what if Biden
and the IRS is going to start looking at
our and it just spirals out of control
and usually they don't say I'm looking
at the news I just say hey turn off the
news turn it off and I go yeah you're
right
um I I've told it on this show but a
buddy of mine who's
um he's a banking commissioner and he's
he's just a brilliant mind when it comes
to money I was hammering him one time
just what about this and what about this
and I was in one of my anxiety spirals
it's all coming down and he finally said
the magic words that was like a light
switch for me and he looked at me and
said hey John I don't have a meteorite
plan
and I was like what's that supposed to
mean he goes I'm going to put money in
retirement I'm going to put money in
this in this program I'm gonna pay my
house off I don't owe anybody on cars
because they're depreciating assets and
it's dumb to borrow money under he just
he's just so so straightforward as a
banker and then he goes and then if I
get hit by a meteorite I'm gonna deal
with that on that day because I'm just
not going to waste my and I was like oh
yeah
so if all the monetary system implodes
and crashes we have bigger issues
there'll be much better that's exactly
right
um that at that point you know what's
going to be your best bet your best
apocalypse bet what's that have close
relationships with your neighbors
know your neighbors so that they don't
look at you as an enemy they look at you
as somebody to do life with and to get
through the next hurdle hurdles that
you're gonna have to overcome together
know your neighbors really really well
that's your best apocalyptic move that's
good not having a bunch of
cryptocurrency they're not gonna want
that the apocalypse the zombies cannot
be bought
my neighbors Gary and Lon they're not
going to be doing much with Dogecoin
nope but they will bring tomatoes sugar
my neighbor gave me some tomatoes from
his garden the other day
Apocalypse Now that we can do it